good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 507 object class
safe special containment procedures as
CP 507 is allowed free roam of the
facility
obviously barring anything that would
breach security or safety protocols
anytime SCP 507 leaves its private
quarters it must be accompanied by an
agent mostly at this point to make sure
that it does not shift without the
facility's knowledge SCP 507 should not
be physically touched if there have been
more than two weeks since its last shift
the risks inherent in disobeying this
protocol make the action its own
punishment should the issue of
disciplinary measures ever come up when
SCP 507 undergoes a shift faculty will
be informed to keep an eye out for its
eventual reappearance it also has a
tracking device implanted into it and a
daily signal check should verify whether
or not
SCP 507 has returned from its trip if it
reappears in or near by the facility SCP
507 will return to its quarters on its
own otherwise a retrieval team of three
plain-clothes agents may be sent to
provide transportation back upon
successful return SCP 507 can be the
subject of various physical tests up
until two weeks after each shift it is
worth noting that SCP 507 has allowed a
computer with an internet connection by
a proxy which sprinkly limits what
information can be uploaded and to where
in its room and may petition to use or
mate with or act as a test subject for
safe or euclid scps that do not affect
mental functions negatively or carry an
infectious trait this is a result of SCP
507 s persistently clean record and the
implication that if SCP 507 was ever
going to be a security leak it
would have used its faux teleportation
powers to do so already it is also worth
considering then SCP 507 is actually
below average in most physical traits
and that even in the worst case
scenarios any SCP agents should be more
than capable of carrying out a
termination order description SCP 507 is
a Caucasian male with blonde hair and
green eyes sporting no other outstanding
characteristics
besides being somewhat overweight and
speaking in a vague accent of disputable
origin although SCP 507 has an already
established name due to its unremarkable
upbringing it seems to find
entertainment enforcing those it meets
to give it a nickname in lieu of
divulging this information thus SCP 507
will now respond to the names Tommy
Steve Rudo Guy Houdini and grab knocked
the destroyer SCP 507 was originally
recovered from the asylum
when standard surveillance equipment
following repeated successful escape
attempts brought its abilities to light
all records of this incident were
confiscated and SCP 507 was taken into
custody under the pretense of moving it
to a more secure facility the original
theory was that SCP 507 possessed some
form of teleportation ability as it
would suddenly disappear and eventually
reappear in a different location
subsequent interviews with the subject
did verify that its ability could be
used in such a manner but that it was
merely a side-effect for its main
affliction SCP 507 holds that during its
periods of disappearance it is actually
displaced into a random alternate
reality the landscape generally stays
the same but the inhabitants and climate
of the parallel world often do not SCP
507 also insists that it has no control
over the time and duration of these
shifts this has been more or less
confirmed by the subject being known to
displace at inconvenient times such as
MIT sent
while sleeping or even while using
on-site public facilities if SCP 507
moves it bound in the alternate world
the eventual shift back will then place
it at the corresponding area in our
reality a sample list of SCP 507 s
descriptions of alternate realities can
be found in document 507 zero mentally
SCP 507 shows no large deviations from
the psychological profile for a normal
person it is confessed to have always
had a great interest in the paranormal
and mythological which has directly led
to its eventual permission to interact
with relatively harmless SCP SCP 507
especially enjoys meeting with other
sentient SCPs
once going so far as to request a small
vacation to visit SCP 82 the request was
eventually granted after persistent
pleading from SCP 507 and the meeting
was thankfully uneventful document 507
zero a sample list of SCP 507 s supposed
extra dimensional travels along with any
demands made by it after returning
subject arrived in complete darkness
leaving it to assume that the current
location was indoors or subterranean
after fumbling a bound for a possible
way out subject heard a sound akin to
muted breathing nearby subject then
decided to curl up in the nearest corner
and wait it out instead of risking a
blind confrontation with an unknown
creature request a standard flashlight
which it now always carries on its
person
subject appeared in a replica of the
facility although apparently fallen into
disuse further exploration led to the
discovery of various corpses strewn
about the area all heavily decayed and
covered in an odd type of mold
upon noting that the corpses seemed to
rhythmically expand and contract as if
still breathing
subject attempted to leave the facility
this idea was quickly discarded but it
opened an exit and found that the
outside world was apparently coated with
the same odd growth request heavy doses
of oricon azul and a fungal expert to
help ascertain the nature of the mold no
exact match of the described mold was
found but it was noted to share many
attributes with certain types of
cordyceps fungi see addendum 507 - upon
reappearing subject was reported to
mutter so many spiders subject refused
to elaborate request a handheld firearm
of any type request was granted under
the stipulation that said firearm is
specifically built to only use rubber
bullets subject once again appeared in a
pitch-black location with breathing
nearby upon turning on its flashlight
subject was surprised by a man wearing a
black business suit and sunglasses with
an impossibly wide smile said smiling
man was apparently leading to ward SCP
507 when it turned on the light the end
result being that their faces were
almost touching smiling man then
remarked back so soon before subject
switched the light off again discharged
all rounds in its firearm at the general
vicinity of the man and once more curled
up into the nearest corner until shifted
back into our reality request none
those with level two security clearance
may read a full list by accessing
document 507 3b forward below is an
archive of all documented shifts
undergone by a CP 507 each of these
entries are presented with their
contents in the following order
dimensional label created upon discovery
of a new reality for ease of later
reference
retrieval used for the documentation of
any complications or anomalies in the
recovery of SCP 507 post shift
description of reality and a description
of any After Effects caused by visiting
said reality and finally request
listings of any special requests made by
507 upon return or for noting any
souvenirs retrieved from the shift 1b
755 II 728 retrieval uneventful subject
arrived in a desert environment and
wandered around for roughly an hour
before encountering another human said
human was wearing a tanned leather
overcoat and was described as completely
unshaven said man was extremely
surprised to find the subject and
demanded that he be followed in order to
lead it back to food and shelter subject
originally began to follow the mat but
intentionally lost contact with him upon
noticing that his leather coat contained
no seams or stitching requests none 92
66 v 7h g v retrieval uneventful subject
arrived in a forest habitat with no
signs of previous or current
industrialization no further anomalies
were perceptible until the subject grew
hungry at which point it discover that
harvesting or eating plant life would
cause them to emit telepathic screams
subject abstained from eating for the
first day because of this but became
hungry enough on the second day onward
to consume the flora in spite of the
screams testing has shown no by law
gold chain jizz in the subject from this
but subject repeatedly affirms that it
felt horrible for doing so
request none specifically but subject
adopted a gelatin and pudding based diet
for two and a half weeks after returning
from this ship j75 r63 3tf retrieval
uneventful subject arrived in a
dimension with flipped genders no
notable differences beside this were
discovered although subjects found issue
with the fact that its female
counterpart looks pretty much the same
as the standard version request nun
dimensional label invalid retrieval by a
tracking device plainclothes agents
found subject sitting in an alleyway at
subject was largely unresponsive upon
retrieval and remained so until the
standard questioning phase when asked
where it went this shift subject
answered nowhere I think I missed it
this time subject experience minor motor
skill impairment and decreased activity
levels for roughly a month after this
shift
request a nightlight and wristwatch
which makes an audible tick as the
second hand moves both were approved j7q
53 y8 st retrieval subject was found in
its quarters sprawled on the floor
attempting to gnaw through the sleeves
of a straitjacket it was wearing the
jacket leg restraints and loss of motor
skills still present from the last shift
led to the subject being unable to stand
up or open the door to find assistance
subject shifted while sleeping and awoke
restrained and lying in a hospital great
bed a nurse informed the subject that he
was still a patient at the asylum and
was currently suffering from advanced
stages of dementia subject was then
sedated and spent the rest of this shift
alternating between semi-consciousness
and total unconsciousness request
disregarding get this thing off me
90 to 66 b7h g52 retrieval subject found
in its quarters balled up with its hands
over its ears subject once again arrived
in the forest habitat from 90 to 66 v 7h
g 5 the florist seemed to have
remembered subjects last visit though
they reacted by screaming for its entire
four-day shift request a hug approved
and they say the foundation is evil 6 k
3:21 bi0 s BN 2 al 6 c te retrieval
uneventful subject arrived in a derelict
metropolitan area subject was unable to
locate any other humans but noted an
overabundance of cats in every area
visited said felines seemed no different
from normal house cats though and
subjects spent most of this shift
petting any who came near during the
standard examination procedures after
retrieval trace amounts of a Toxoplasma
gondii variant were discovered on the
subjects clothing as well as larger
amounts on its shoes further testing
showed that the subject had not yet been
infected with the toxoplasmosis variant
most likely attributed to the short time
frame of this shift not allowing the
subject to grow hungry and seek out food
all clothing and belongings that were on
the subjects person during this shift
were incinerated and the subject forced
to undergo special decontamination
procedures in order to prevent any
possibility of contagion requests a pair
of rubber gloves denied on the basis
that hand protection would not have
protected subject from infection in any
way
one twenty five twenty eight P OS for
three retrieval via tracking device
subject was attempting to return on its
own but was making less progress than
usual due to the discomfort of doing so
subject once again arrived in a
pitch-black area with muted breathing
nearby subject decided to seek an exit
this time via blind wandering subject
eventually found itself at the mouth of
a corridor with what appeared to be a
light source at the end subject began to
run towards the light upon noticing this
as it grew closer the light suddenly
grew in intensity and the subject was
exposed to searing pain subject passed
out at this point and only awoke after
it it shifted back examination upon
retrieval revealed that the subjects
epidermis had been clearly stripped down
to the stratum granulosum in all areas
open to sunlight and down to the stratum
lucidum in all areas covered by clothing
requests none but subject reappeared
wearing a pair of large heavily tinted
sunglasses subject did not notice that
it was wearing these until they were
pointed out and supposed that they were
probably why its eyes didn't undergo the
same process as its skin 7f2 wa3 193
retrieval uneventful subject arrived in
an urban area with no major changes as
far as it could tell subject used the
public computers of a library to search
for differences between this dimension
and hours eventually finding that
Abraham Lincoln was assassinated by his
vice-president in order to claim his
position this ultimately led to the
presidency becoming a tribe leader like
position where the current holder is
legally allowed to be challenged and
overthrown by other suitable candidates
subject noted with great surprise that
this change did not do much to alter the
times that most major presidents took
and held in office many of the minor
and/or detrimental presidencies tended
to end via bullet wounds often in
unlikely locales or from improbable
angles which deterred most from
attempting coup
at all requests not ws6 ECU 83 d
retrieval uneventful subject arrived at
the mouth of the cave surrounded by
almost unbearable heat subject walked
outside the cave for further
investigation to find that the area
around it was a baked wasteland most of
the heat appear to emanate from two suns
in the sky the subject could not decide
whether they were extremely large or
extremely close to the planet upon
further examination the Suns blinked and
turned away taking the heat with them
subjects spent the rest of this shift as
far back in the cave as possible
requests none q56
d ru 865 retrieval subject found in the
cafeteria masticating on what appeared
to be upon containment subject uttered
the words more more more before losing
consciousness subject regained
consciousness two hours later expressing
a strong desire for pudding
when questioned subject claimed to see
the biggest mound of pudding ever
when questioned as to why it was
masticating upon arrival subject claimed
to be eating a glob of pudding at the
time subject reported seeing bowling
around the hallways hallucinations
passed within 24 hours requests pudding
request granted
F 24 9s 633 C retrieval subject found in
service tunnel 6 R 3 B K without
original equipment subject was wearing a
simple uniform with a similar design to
the current foundation d-class uniform
subject shifted while dining in the
cafeteria destination dimension had an
analogue to the foundation with a
facility in the same location although
internal layout had significant
differences security responded to
subject is an
tutor and detained it immediately during
this process this subject was imprisoned
and stripped of all equipment including
tracking device for the remainder of the
shift subject underwent repeated
questioning the foundation analog
refused to accept subjects explanation
off dimension-hopping information
gleaned from post shift debriefing
indicates that f 24 9 s 633 C has a
foundation analog in the Society for
containment of the paranormal this
analog has a strong British influence
and is opposed by the covert occult
group and the Church of the mending God
further details remain unclear as the
society refused to answer the subjects
questions and only slip details by
assuming it knew them already request
replacement equipment request granted
for GT f 1q h 17 retrieval subject was
found by the cafeteria kitchen staff of
cypher drenched covered in mud and
suffering from severe hypothermia
subject arrived in what appeared to be a
large field during a rainstorm subject
attempted to find shelter from the rain
but found none remaining in the rain for
the entire shift after an unknown length
of time the subject reported seeing
entities in the distance
although the heavy rain obscured the
subject from obtaining a detailed report
of their appearances the subject
described them as being vaguely humanoid
in shape the entities began to slowly
move towards the subject from all
directions near the end of the shift the
subject reported hearing labored
breathing from the nearest entity's
request a set of warm clothing approved
- aw 9 u 2 e 5 t retrieval uneventful
subject arrived in midair
falling from an outdoor environment into
a subterranean body of water at the
bottom of a large cavern though
admittedly experiencing a strong surge
of adrenaline from this event subject
reported swimming a long way before
reaching land subsequent observation
revealed a giant hole in the ceiling of
the cavern through which subject had
apparently fallen also reported were
archways two other large caverns most
with shafts of sunlight visible
indicating other surface collapses
regular vertical grooves in the walls
indicate possible excavation
despite the caverns immense size no
other sign of life was observed before
returning subject realized that the
possibility of shifting back to our
reality so far underground might cause
it to be displaced in solid rock and
spent its remaining time frantically
searching for a way back to the surface
when subject succeeded it discovered
that the sinkholes were much more
widespread than what had been visible
from below ground requests driving
lessons
denied
to you you 5:19 q3d
retrieval upon seeing foundation
personnel its subject approached them
and requested to be rican tained sharing
knowledge of scps that were of level
three clearance the length of time the
subject was absent from our reality was
notable being roughly three months in
length however during this time it made
several notable discoveries including
several SCPs uncontained by our
realities SCP foundation but contained
by universe to you you 5:19 q 3ds
equivalent these SCPs have now been
contained through this three months
timeframe the subject managed to become
a member of two uu 5:19 q3 DS SCP
foundation equivalent working its way up
the ranks far faster than would have
been anticipated assuming it had been
made a member of foundation personnel on
the same day at the time of its return
he was apparently in the field working
to contain 2 uu 5:19 q3 DS equivalent of
SCP curiously our foundation had sent
out a task force for precisely the same
reason on the same day further links
between universe 2 uu 519 Q 3 D and our
reality are being investigated requests
to be made a member of site personnel
denied 3 JT 3 MD d IG retrieval subject
retrieved via implanted tracker medivac
required to second subject was a mobile
upon retrieval due to greatly increased
body mass measured kilograms lead
research approved emergency use of SCP
394 to keep it alive in order to obtain
a report upon recovery subject reported
being surrounded by really big creatures
resembling
they quickly trapped him in a
transparent container it was then
transported an unknown distance to a
shiny surface whereupon the creatures
began to observe him after approximately
one day tubes were inserted into unknown
fluid which was not found upon
examination subject reported that the
tubes were removed shortly before the
shift and an observed approaching it
presumably for the purpose of extraction
request services of a personal trainer
doctor has agreed to let the subject
borrow her workout tapes subject now
displays a strong aversion to put it 9 j
3 y 6 X DT wine retrieval the subject
was found hanging from its ankles in a
tree on site subject was partially
encased in insulated reflective titanium
armor upon retrieval the subject
described the world that had arrived in
as extra shiny and stated that it was
apprehended by law enforcement officers
upon retrieval after being apprehended
the subject was transported to a nearby
manufacturing facility and placed upside
down on an assembly line where a series
of metal sheets were shaped and cut to
fit its body it briefly had time to ask
what was going on and was informed that
the radiation from the Sun was extremely
dangerous and titanium reflective suits
were required by law to prevent thermal
radiation damage to any person or
structure requests sunscreen and eye
exam granted 5 - J 0 7 9 3 gh retrieval
via a tracking device subject was found
inside a padlocked metal shed behind an
abandoned house on the outskirts of
subject arrived in a small room housing
several dried corpses beside said
corpses the room was mostly bare the
only things subject noted were a single
painless window and a light fixture on
the ceiling which occasionally flickered
subject attempted to rise to his feet
but had difficulty doing so due to
repeated and unpredictable surges of
motion
subject eventually made its way to the
window at which point it discovered that
its room was actually a container
suspended in midair by a large chain
subject watched as similar containers
passed by him and as it passed by others
by a complex web of rails above it which
the chains were attached to subject
could see nothing besides this but
darkness in all directions subject then
tried to wait out its time in this
dimension by falling asleep but found it
difficult due to a newly discovered
quality of the corpses during moments of
darkness caused by flickering the
corpses rearrange themselves into poses
which would be logical for living people
during that particular moment if the
subject was looking out the window the
corpses would be crowded around him in
an attempt to get a better view if the
subject was sitting they would also be
seated in a pattern to form a circle if
the subject attempted to reach the light
fixture they would act as a support or
seemed to be in the process of pushing
him upwards etc request nun the area
which the subject exited though has been
cordoned off and is currently under
surveillance if no evidence of
foundation worthy phenomena has been
experienced by an anonymous tip will be
sent to local law enforcement agencies
so that they can discover the crime
scene and take appropriate investigative
actions on their own YT f 5n 2q 0 0
retrieval uneventful subject arrived in
a crowded casino like area subject noted
that the only type of machine available
was something similar to slots but they
apparently required no money to play and
gave out nothing upon a win upon
actually sitting down in front of one
and trying it the subject discovered
that the machine dispensed a small slip
of paper with writing on it upon every
pull of the lever and spin of the
symbols it displayed subject could
discern no real pattern to what symbol
would produce what type of note but
wrote down a list of its attempts and
what it received from each just in case
Joule Crescent claw if given a slice of
death could you tell how large
it was hammer Crescent Crescent a poor
bass leads to rushed patch jobs present
hammer jewel de ja who cloth circle
hammer
there are things worse than death for
one not dying present hammer Crescent
there will always be someone to look
after you present jewel Crescent there
not that jolly it's just stuck that way
hammer Crescent hammer there will always
be something to look after claw claw
claw the future's looking bright request
none
afn 305 p khc retrieval uneventful
subject appeared in a white corridor
with steel doors lining both walls each
door had a keypad a small speaker system
and a clipboard containing forms written
in undecipherable characters as the
subject approached one door to examine
set clipboard the doors attached speaker
turned on and began to address it
subject was informed that the voice
belonged to the person locked behind
that specific door and that he was
wrongfully imprisoned then left to die
the prisoner then pleaded with the
subject to release him from his cell
subject jokingly replied that he would
free the prisoner if he promised not to
stab the subject upon release there was
roughly a seven second pause before the
prisoner asked what stabbing was after a
moment of deliberation the subject
defined stabbing as the creation of a
new orifice through the use of a pointed
object another pause followed the
prisoner eventually affirmed that he
could not stab the subject because all
of his objects were very blunt subject
naturally did not open that door or any
of the others requests none I 5237 g7 8m
retrieval by a tracking device subject
was in a holding cell of the police
station under charges of public
indecency extraction was successfully
made with no complications subject
arrived in an area apparently undergoing
a large snowstorm subject attempted to
find shelter but could not find its way
in the storm and it almost completely
succumbed to exposure by the time it was
located and pulled into a cave by a man
covered in protective furs the man
helped the subject out of its soaked
clothing although he did not have an
extra set of garments he led the subject
to an underground hot spring his cave
was connected to when the man was sure
that the subject was regaining its
strength he removed his furs and entered
the spring as well
subject was extremely surprised that
discovered that the man was a second SCP
507 subject noticed no obvious physical
differences between itself and the
double although the alternate 507 had a
pattern of tribal scarring across his
torso as well as the basis of some of
his limbs subject and the double
remained in the cave and conversed with
each other until the subject shift ended
request subject drew a replica of the
alternate 507 scars for memory and asked
for any information on possible cultural
or symbolic meaning behind the patterns
none were found
but foundation researchers noted that
the lines were congruent with incision
marks which would have been made during
a standard s 4351 u p09 retrieval by a
tracking device subject recovered in a
cornfield with unidentified brown liquid
splattered on its cheek a human heart
with the words I need you written in the
same liquid was discovered in the
subjects hand subject claimed that said
object was not in its possession during
the shift and does not know how it came
into its possession researchers are
attempting to identify the liquid
subject arrived in pitch-black darkness
with the sound of crying nearby upon
activating its flashlight subject
discovered the smiling man from previous
shifts leaning towards him brown liquid
leaked from around its sunglasses
smiling men pushed its face closer to
the subject and uttered the phrase why
did you do this smiling man then wiped
off a portion of the brown liquid from
its eyes with its hand and began
caressing subjects cheek with it subject
forcefully pushed smiling man away
subject observed that the smiling man's
business suit contains several holes
with brown liquid trailing down from
them subject drew its firearm and pulled
the trigger
however for unknown reasons the pistol
did not find
smiling man began slowly walking towards
the subject subject ran for
approximately ten minutes and spent the
rest of the shift huddled in the corner
request a more reliable pistol denied as
the cause of error is unknown ninety-two
sixty-six v 7h g five three retrieval
via tracking device subject was
discovered seven kilometers northeast of
the facility subject shifted while
reading in its quarters subject found
itself returned to the forest habitat
containing telepathic trees the trees
remain silent upon its entry to the
environment the subject admitted that
despite its previous experiences within
the environment it was curious about the
absence of any human habitation the
subject propelled itself to the highest
ground it could find in order to see
over the tree canopy the subject found a
clearing on top of a hill subject
reported seeing a huge semi translucent
blue dome covering the entire forest the
tree canopy extended out to the edge of
the dome with foliage so thick that
looking up and through it was unfeasible
subject reported itself to see the domes
slightly off-center suggesting it was
not underneath the direct middle request
none 5z for 75 T 7yb retrieval subject
was found prone and unresponsive in its
quarters subject was bleeding
significantly several deep gashes were
found in the left side of the subject
just under the armpit the claw marks
extended to the bottom of the rib cage
subject received traditional first aid
and was committed to the on-site
infirmary
the subject woke up on a snow-covered
plane subject did not have its backpack
on hand at the time of the shift
having been asleep all that went with it
was its bedsheets and pajamas subject
reports having seen a TV show of how to
survive in a cold environment before the
shift
it attempted to build a large crude snow
cave using its hands when it was
interrupted by a large white bear this
is the extent of its recollection
request a proper weapon granted losing
subject to a non-anomalous polar bear
would be a waste of foundation resources
and an embarrassment subject shall
receive a knife sheath and belt and is
required to keep these items on its
person at all times 3g 814 h 9u x
retrieval rican tained in the kitchen
missing left hand and using expletives
in an uncontrolled fashion the subject
was returned to the infirmary the
subject transitioned into a dimension
very similar to our own at first glance
the subject was apprehended by
foundation personnel in the infirmary
and questioned about his small canines
the subject admitted to not knowing what
that meant but quickly worked it out
after his interview opened his mouth and
pointed to a large set of fangs located
on either side of its incisors the
interview also commented on the subjects
roundish body shape which was considered
unusual and fascinating in this
dimension despite these differences the
subject described the creatures who
interviewed it as kind they proceeded to
bring the subject a large amount of food
the subject noted a distinct lack of
anything green in the meal offered to
him when later told to elaborate by
foundation personnel he stated it was
all meat after eating the meal two of
the creatures containing the subject in
their equivalent of the infirmary
escorted him into a small room nearby
containing a locket hanging on the
opposite wall they told the subject to
remove its clothes and stand in front of
the locket after the subject had done as
ordered they opened the locket and
exposed it to a green orb for
approximately eight minutes the subject
noted the lack of any scar tissue on his
left side and a strong feeling of
general well-being the next day
a creature came to him and asked for a
small portion of his skin and
musculature in order to study genetic
differences to
this the subject responded with only if
you provide me with another delicious
meal the creature was visibly excited by
this outcome a small biopsy was
conducted on the subjects upper right
thigh the subject described this
experience as painful but totally worth
it a huge amount of unspecified meat was
delivered to the subject upon completion
of the biopsy the subject was then
released to explore the facility for the
next month and a half
the creatures continued to supply the
subject with mounds of meat and engage
it in amiable conversation the subject
acquired 14 kilograms of fat during this
time on April 16th 2015 the subject was
escorted to the kitchen equivalent it
was then put on a chopping block and its
left hand was removed request a
replacement hand granted ate a 8 9 1 T
710 retrieval uneventful subject arrived
in a large opaque dome filled with
plants without sign of human habitation
subject stated that walking was
difficult and uncomfortable upon further
investigation the subject found a window
displaying what was described as
pitch-black with earth on the horizon
several minutes later a tall humanoid
encountered the subject inquiring about
his comparative short stature subject
replied asking where he was
the humanoid stated that they were in
base 12 oxygen and vegetable subject
asked what earth was doing in the sky
humanoid appeared puzzled and responded
that's the moon gesturing to earth a
short argument ensued and the humanoid
departed subject noted that after the
earth set a rocky grey landscape became
visible becoming identifiable as the
lunar surface after an hour or so
subject attempted to explore more of his
surroundings but shifted back to our
reality after setting out
request one camera subject stated the
view is breathtaking
denied 7j zero 175 35 X retrieval
subject was rican tained on the roof of
the facility after having fallen
approximately 5 meters subject shifted
while attempting to fall asleep subject
arrived in a large body of water
believed to be freshwater by the
description of its taste subjects swam
upward an estimated 35 meters before
reaching the surface of the water and
beginning to tread subject noted several
dark shapes moving in the water beneath
it and bright lights in the distance but
it did not attempt to approach either
subject reportedly found breathing
extremely difficult subsequent physical
tests indicated that the subject had
ingested substantial amounts of methane
during the shift request a tank of
breathing gas as part of its equipment
approved 99 P UT 124 J retrieval subject
was found in the location which it had
left curled up and crying violently
subjects screamed why did I have to go
when an attempt was made to interact
with it and suffered from severe
depression for several days thereafter
agents described a beautiful smell
coming from it subject landed in a place
it could only describe as impossibly
beautiful subject stated that it was
like the best part of every place all
put together and that the beauty was so
overwhelming that the subject had no
desire to move when it began to become
thirsty and hungry plants apparently
extended vines and shot liquid into its
mouth which it described as the best
anything I have ever drunk ever sweet
and rich and everything all at once
after roughly one day subject having
never looked at his watch during this
time at no clear knowledge of the
duration a humanoid female subjects age
unexpectedly encountered subject as she
walked over a hill subject claimed that
they had a long conversation despite not
speaking the same
language and was unable to explain how
this was possible or the form of their
communication had taken subject claimed
that he understood her answers to his
questions and about her in their
location but was unable to articulate
them subject described her with I know
I'm sounding repetitive here but she was
the most amazing person I have ever met
with some reluctance subjects stated
that they have been about to kiss when
the shift ended subject then had to be
prevented from committing suicide tests
after successful psychiatric treatment
indicated subject was considerably more
physically fit and had gained roughly
eight IQ points despite having done no
significant exercise during the shift
request various foods beverages and
pictures of women widely regarded as
very physically attractive the subject
considered all granted requests
unsatisfactory making statements such as
it's not the same and no no no not like
that subject then requested a way to
stay in a universe permanently after
having arrived there and was reminded
that it was impossible
6a 593 w 132 retrieval subject returned
malnourished and suffering from the
effects of an unknown toxic substance
from which it soon recovered later
analysis showed the substance to be a
venom containing a high level of silicon
a small silicon based crystalline
creature was hanging from the subjects
finger when the subject returned this
specimen subsequently died of unknown
causes possibly starvation subject
shifted to a dimension which primarily
contained crystals of varying sizes and
hues the son was described by the
subject as smaller and bluer than ours
the ground was covered in sand and also
various dull colors the subject noted
that many of the larger crystals were
moving slowly and appeared to be alive
it also saw smaller creatures which
scuttled around rapidly and seemed to be
composed of crystal the subject spent
some time searching for water which it
found that noted that there seemed to be
considerably more of the smaller
crystalline animals near the water
shortly before the subject returned it
was attacked by one of the small
creatures the subject described both the
larger and the smaller creatures as both
looking and behaving similarly to
crustaceans request food and water that
doesn't taste like sand granted 7xj hg
577 be retrieval subject appeared in its
quarters highly agitated d 37 62 and the
handcuffs binding the two together were
reported missing subject before the
shift was handcuffed to d 37 62 a
convicted serial killer subject was
instructed to terminate d 37 62 if
either of them were placed in mortal
danger 507 shifted to a dimension where
a second Ice Age was occurring on earth
immediately after landing d 37 62 and
the subject were captured by agents of a
post-apocalyptic SCP foundation the
former was immediately recognized as
d-class and was swiftly terminated by an
vidual claiming to be agent 507 was
placed in a cell in the lower levels of
a facility called psycho subject recalls
that from the interrogation the agents
believed that it was a junior researcher
attempting to help D 3760 to escape from
the foundation during the interrogation
the subject shifted back into our
dimension request replacement gear
granted t34 de to zero for F retrieval
subject was found in Sector a highly
restricted area subject was swiftly
removed subject shifted to a dimension
with a world covered in water subject
then equipped its scuba gear and decided
to see what was below the water subject
descended for approximately three
minutes and believed that it traveled 50
meters down before seeing the ocean
floor the floor was covered with
abandoned buildings and rubble corroded
and covered with aqueous plant life
several skeletons could be seen subject
had searched the underwater city for
three minutes when the subject spotted
three black fish-like creatures moving
towards it at an estimated speed of 10
meters per second subject drew his knife
and firearm before shifting back into
our dimension request a pair of
waterproof binoculars approved a 60d
9975 q retrieval subject returned to the
site wearing an elaborate costume made
of silks wool and several unidentified
mammals subject appeared in an empty
Halle way of a futuristic city inhabited
by a large variety of unknown humanoid
entities when subject encountered said
entities they appeared startled at its
presence and began vocalizing loudly and
seemed to become agitated eventually the
equivalent of the local authorities took
the subject into custody and were able
to communicate with it when questioned
about how he arrived their subjects
stated it had amnesia and could
recall the last several years subject
then questioned the origin of the
various beings and the reason for their
presence on earth said authorities
explain to the subject that after Earth
had suffered ACK class end of the world
scenario based on the description given
it is hypothesized that the event was
caused by a CP the earth left with a
greatly reduced human population was
subsequently colonised by various
extraterrestrial races the few remaining
humans on the planet mostly inhabited
isolated areas away from the alien
cities these authorities then offered to
take the subject to the nearest of these
locations but subject refused insisting
that its stay among the
extraterrestrials
it appears the subject status as one of
the few remaining humans comfortable
with the presence of the aliens combined
with a large number of facts fabricated
about life on Earth prior to the seek a
class scenario allowed the subject to
gain a high social profile as part of
the alien society becoming something of
a celebrity during the two weeks it's
spent and shift request a camera to but
a record and document events and sights
experienced during the shifts approved Z
73 3 DD 89 e retrieval subject was found
in the basement of a house subject
arrived in an airship of some sort
flying across what appeared to be a
mountainous region subject reported
meeting several humanoids it described
as dwarfs and elves similar to those
found in typical high fantasy literature
these beings were supposedly mercenaries
investigating an anomaly in their world
described as a dragon having falling
from the sky subject requested to join
them in their mission getting excited to
partake in an apparently fantastical
adventure after landing at the site of
the mission subject was reluctantly
convinced to stay on the airship as the
mission would likely be dangerous
eventually getting impatient subject
investigated the cave in which the
supposed dragon hit on its own managing
to take a picture of a massive
reptilian creature with metallic scales
and wings with its camera just as it
shifted back the picture is described by
foundation staff as sick of the subject
repeatedly affirmed that a child wearing
a large pointed hat appeared just before
the shift and grabbed its leg request a
Dungeons and Dragons fifth edition
players handbook granted CZE 582 7 DG
retrieval uneventful subject appeared in
the bedroom of a cute suburban looking
house and was greeted by several people
of varying age and race they welcomed
him to their home and showed him around
the building subject noted an abundance
of windows in the building upon looking
outside noticed that the house was
encased in a large glass dome and was
being viewed by several cameras the
residents explained that they were part
of a zoo like enclosure subject was not
distressed as he knew he would
eventually return to the foundation
subjects spent the next several days
meeting the residents and relaxing while
waiting to return request none DRK 0:38
891 retrieval SCP 507 was found in dr.
king's office subject appeared in what
seemed to be an endless forest of apple
trees it was inhabited by a race of
humanoids all of whom appeared identical
to dr. King the entities seemed to
recognize SCP 507 and gave him a message
to pass on to dr. king
come home lost child we have sent you
the signs countless times yet you still
do not come do you not remember the holy
orchard of your birth the wind through
the trees the crisp delight of her holy
fruit please come home we miss you
request to pass message on to dr. King
denied for the safety of SCP 507 SCP ld9
431 retrieval uneventful subject
appeared in a highly furnished version
of its own containment chamber after
leaving the chamber it has discovered
that the facility was inverted from the
main reality in the sense that all of
the offices were replaced with
containment chambers and vice versa
further inquiry revealed that foundation
staff were being contained due to their
ability to create dangerous experiments
the primary containment staff consisted
of more docile versions of the baseline
realities humanoids in containment
notably less hostility did not make
their lack of containment any safer
causing the facility to be filled with
biological mimetic and other hazards it
is unknown how a cake last scenario has
not occurred despite the apparent lack
of containment d-class and non research
staff were unchanged request heightened
psychological evaluations on staff
I swear you guys aren't telling us
something about 507 it didn't bring
anything dangerous back somehow and
never does not to mention it wasn't a
mental institution and aspires to be a
researcher agent McDaniels addendum 507
3b zero zero due to a particularly
trying encounter several documents and
the archives have been altered corrupted
or technically never existed document
507 3b appears to have been affected by
this and is currently being rebuilt
using backup files references and
respectively subject matter may
occasionally increase decrease or
undergo modifications in light of this
doctor those with level 2 507 security
clearance should also see interview 507
G for evidence of a particularly
noteworthy shift and this is interview
507 G interviewed SCP 507 and SCP 507
interviewer dr. forward during a daily
signal check for CP 507 two independent
verifications were returned the
following investigation led to the
discovery of identical SCP 507
duplicates in its assigned quarters both
apparently made their way to the room by
themselves and it spent less than half
an hour conversing with each other upon
meeting the following interview took
place between them and the first
informed employee to reach their
location playing log now hey welcome to
the party I'm afraid you're going to
have to explain this to me there's
apparently one more version of view of
this problem should have seen this
coming honestly there are so many ways
an alternate reality could differ
without affecting my personal life you
know so which one of you is the visitor
is something wrong we've actually been
talking about this for a bit now you
guys have been real nice to us more than
we deserve really but they also know
that this could be or other enticing
opportunity for your research department
it'd probably be best if you didn't know
which one of us was temporary expendable
I don't know what kind of stories you
two have been sharing but our job is to
secure and protect the likes of you
perhaps this other reality has a less
benign code of conduct perhaps oh I can
shoot fireballs for my mouth we don't
need to be hurtful but this place isn't
the best source of human compassion and
I'm sure that there's at least one
person on staff who would love breaking
the open in an attempt to find out how
all this freaky stuff works if it wasn't
for the fact that you couldn't keep
studying me after if you have to put it
like that I have enough things to keep
me awake at night
god no once there was this guy with a
huge assignment and who nearly soiled
myself
you know this could be interpreted as a
security breach who's the doppelganger
gonna report to alternate SCP and fairly
sure that there's a better chance of a
meteoric striking this place and
successful cross-dimensional sabotage
actually came across at least three
dimensions where something fell from
you're not helping yeah I rarely do
anyway well now that how visitors left I
have a question all right did you figure
out the difference between your
realities actually I think I did in his
world
Abraham Lincoln was killed while
sleeping by his vice-president instead
of by General Lee in this reality Booth
assassinated Lincoln
closing statement subsequent testing
revealed Dennis cp5 o7s abilities have
no biological basic and that severed
pieces will still shift along with the
main body the SCP 507 of this reality
reappeared three days later and has not
been informed of this incident
addendum 507 0 agent went missing on at
the same time as SCP 507 a full-scale
search was launched to find either of
them only four SCP 507 to appear a week
later when questioned it said that was
holding on to its shoulder when it
shifted leading to both of them to
appear in an alternate dimension where
during the ensuing chaos SCP 507 lost
contact with and could not relocate him
before it shifted back to standard
reality a new protocol has been placed
in light of this no one is to come into
contact with SCP 507 after 2 weeks
following a displacement reevaluation of
previous incidents has shown that there
have always been at least two weeks
between each so this time frame will be
the only safe time to touch SCP 507
until further notice addendum 507 1 I
don't care how much he grumbles about it
SCP 507 is not to be cleared for
challenging SCP 76 to 250 rounds of Tic
Tac Toe just know doctor
addendum 507 to fungus encountered by
NCP 507 seems similar to that resulting
from experimentation with SCP 407 huh I
wonder if there's a dimension out there
that I'm the king and everyone
appreciates me yeah anyway I think that
about does it for today don't you thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
good bye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to research her Brandon Connell
Burlington the cop slump god Justin day
Pierce M Hamlin white crew beware 600
Bryson Billy my archive trader Nick
Tiger bull Judi Dench cheese whip
Grayson West the administrator courts 5
6 3 & tree hero if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you